keep an eye on your mailbox Clark County  voters should expect to receive sample  ballots some have already arrived and  some will be delivered in the next week  or so if you opted to get your sample  ballot via email you should already have  it you'll also get a list of polling  places open for early voting and on  Election Day the sample ballots going  out to about 1.3 million registered  voters in Clark County  8 news now is of course your local  election headquarters on Saturday  evening we will be hosting a debate  between the candidates for Nevada's  fourth congressional district they will  square off right here Saturday evening  and come at Steven Horsford and  Challenger Sam Peters will take on the  issue Saturday at 9pm